the five former Memphis police officers
charged in the beating death of Tyree
Nichols faced a judge for the first time
Friday all five pleaded not guilty to
second-degree murder and other charges
just weeks after the police department
released body Cam and Street pool
footage of the traffic stop and arrest
that led to the 29 year old's death
Elise Preston was in the courtroom
not guilty one by one and wearing masks
the five former Memphis police officers
all pleaded not guilty through their
attorneys to second-degree murder and
other charges in the brutal beating
death of Tyree Nichols they didn't even
have the courage to look at me in my
face nichols's mother rovonne Wells was
inside the courtroom I feel very numb
right now I'm really waiting for
somebody to wake me up but I also know
that's not going to happen Nichols died
January 10 three days after he was
repeatedly kicked and punched by the
officers who were part of the now
disbanded scorpion Street crime unit
defense attorneys believe still
unreleased video will show why their
clients pleaded not guilty we have a
very long road of investigation and
litigation ahead of us and I implore the
public to be patient Shelby County
district attorney Steve moldroy says
there are an additional 20 hours of
video that show other angles of what
happened this is an important case and
you know if we are going to hold police
officers who violate the law accountable
then we need to make sure that we get
the prosecution correct we get it right
Nichols death sparked a protest
Nationwide and renewed calls for
stricter police reforms so I don't think
that we can just unilaterally say we're
going to do away with all types of
specialized units but when we talk about
promotions when we're talking about
consequences for turning off the body
cams those are some of the type of
little solutions that we're going to
have to come up with to address this
moving forward the five fired officers
are due back in court in May meanwhile
dozens of community leaders are calling
on the Department of Justice to launch
an investigation into the Memphis Police
Department to see if there is routine
use of excessive force for CBS Saturday
morning I'm Elise Preston Memphis
Tennessee